- [Kaylan] Come on, we're so close.
All we need to do is to decide
how we're going to end the pitch.
- I say we end with a simple pie chart.
Numbers and statistics demonstrate
that we mean business.
- Or, we come up with
a really catchy slogan
and slap it over some awesome clipart.
- Elliot, what do you think?
- Is it hot in here?
- Elliot, you want to go home, right?
- Not really, me and my cat
are in a fight right now, so...
- Right, but you want me to go home.
- Yeah, sure.
- Okay, so vote for my way,
The Digital High-Five.
- That's not fair, you're pressuring him.
- What, madame, I most certainly am not!
- Is he pressuring you?
- Ummm...
- Elliot, you can tell me.
- Well, now you're pressuring him
to say that I'm pressuring him.
- I'm, I'm going to go get some water.
I'm parched.
- Look, my way is the clear winner.
We end with cold, hard facts.
Evidentiary proof that we deliver.
- Hm, there's a surprise.
Ayna wants to be cold and emotionless.
- Companies like to know the bottom line.
- Here's the bottom line.
- Nice segway.
- Thanks.
The bottom line is
companies want to know
that we have their back.
My way is about heart.
- [Ayna] With nothing concrete
and specific to back it up.
Your way is all based on talk.
Sound familiar?
- Elliot, isn't my way the
company you'd want to hire?
- I, I feel like anything I say-
- This is business.
We should end the pitch letting them know
that we're professionals.
- I know what you're going to say.
That this is about compromise.
- [Ayna] No one was going to say that!
- Hey, maybe we can call
Charlie and see what he thinks.
- No, Elliot! This is your moment!
- Oh, I don't want a moment.
- Which is it, Elliot?
Me or Kaylan?
- [Kaylan] Yeah, Elliot, who's right?
- What, you guys are both right.
You both have valid points, and...
Both smell great, and...
Both good people, so...
I'm going to just...
We're all professionals here so,
I don't know why you have to
bring me in the middle
of this whole thing...
I just want to go home
and make up with my cat.
Mr. Harris is waiting for me right now.
He's probably in bed.
(bouncy music)
- So I guess we'll go with mine.
- Alright, I didn't really
care that much anyway.
- [Voiceover] A-mark (snap)
- [Ayna] Woah.
- [Elliot] Oof, brrr.
It's like beeeeep.
(Ayna laughs)
(film reel scrolling)